dubois sûrement encore là je
suis à la recherche de quelque chose
d'un peu d'impôts inhabituel et de
merveilleux
quelque chose de magique
[Musique]
ne t'inquiète pas je vais revenir et si
quelqu'un te poses des questions répond
que tu es
bienvenue chez vous
voici mon crocodile enzo
tiens j'allais de bord des larmes
il n'est pas dangereux c'est un
crocodile mais il se sent seul comme moi
et tu es déjà réveillé il parle pas mais
il sait chanter c'est simple d'eau
one way
car bien trop candide dans le couloir
[Musique]
un véritable cauchemar via un crocodile
dans notre grenier
ce que tu viens de faire c'était trop
incroyable ses fruits la ville doit
faire quelque chose
depuis que je le connais les choses ont
beaucoup changé dans ma vie
et pas que dans le même temps la vôtre
aussi
c'est canada
les gens doivent comprendre qu'ils n'ont
pas à avoir peur de lui
à
toutes les unités on a un crocodile sur
une moto
non
dès lors des mecs